- Today I want to talk
about three principles
that changed my life and these learnings
are influenced by my six
years working in consulting
at McKinsey, but also my subsequent roles
in industry and startup
as a C-level executive.
So welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel, Firm Learning.
I'm sticking to water
today, because it is already
quite late here in Germany.
And without further ado, I want to start
with the first principle,
and this is about
how to achieve financial freedom,
but I must warn you, because the truth,
what I'm going to share,
is maybe quite different
from what you are expecting.
Many people seem to believe that saving
is the best way to
achieve financial freedom,
and I also myself have
talked about the importance
of saving in the past.
I will link some videos
about this above there.
But what does financial
freedom really mean?
And surely there are different
definitions out there.
What I like is the definition that is used
by the FIRE movement.
FIRE stands for financial
independence, retire early.
It's a group of people
set themselves the goal
to not work throughout
their whole working life,
but at some point stop
working and be able to live
just from your capital
and the capital gains,
and this is exactly the definition
I want to adopt for this video.
Financial independence
means that you don't need
to work anymore and you can live
purely on your capital gains.
But what would it really take
to achieve financial independence?
And one rule commonly applied
in the personal finance
community is the 4% rule, and
this means that on average,
if you have your capital invested in a mix
of stocks and bonds, you can
expect that you can achieve
a 4% pre-tax return in
perpetuity, more or less,
without bankrupting your capital.
And from this 4%, you deduct about 25%
as capital gains tax
as is commonly applied,
for instance, in Germany
and other countries,
you will end up with
about 3% post-tax returns
that you can expect on your capital.
This is, of course, a
simplified calculation,
but one that might be quite helpful here.
So if you work with such a
3% rule, what is the capital
that you need in order to
be financially independent?
Of course, the number
differs for everyone.
In my simple mind, I'd say
if you have four million euro
or $4 million, doesn't matter that much
in the current euro-dollar parity.
If you have four million euro
invested and apply 3% to that,
that means that you have
actually a net disposable income
after tax of 120,000 euro per year,
or 10,000 euro per month.
So 10,000 euro per month
for your free disposal.
I'd say most people would say that yes,
they would consider themselves
financially independent
if they achieved this.
With this rule of thumb of 3%,
you can calculate for yourself
what your target number
would be, but let's, for
the sake of this argument,
stick with the four million euro.
So what do you need for that?
What does it take to
have four million euros
saved at some time?
Well, let's imagine there is someone
who earns on average 100,000
thousand euros per year gross
before tax, based on annual employment,
on average throughout their
working life of 40 years.
And arguably, if you were able to do that,
you are surely one of the
more successful people, right?
I'd argue it's quite difficult on average
over a period of 40 years to earn
such a high-profile
salary, even if you work
in a high-paced careers
in banking and so on, why?
Because of course, the first
years you will earn less,
because you're just a junior.
Then maybe there's a
certain period in your life
where you have these high salaries,
but then many people
also during the course
of their career at some point
also start earning less again,
because maybe also these fast-paced
types of jobs are not right for them.
This is my perspective.
Let me know what you think
about this in the comments.
But if you stick with
these numbers, so 40 years,
100,000 euro per year, this
means that after 40 years,
you will have earned
four million Euro, right?
So these are more or less
your lifetime earnings
for someone working in a
fast-paced, high-profile career.
So based on this, you can see that yes,
it is possible to have four
million euros lifetime earnings,
but the problem, of course,
is that this is before tax,
before social security contributions.
This can easily consume
half of this amount,
and then you need to pay for rent,
for living expenses, for
the tuition of your kids.
So even if you are such a high earner,
saving four million euro
will be extremely difficult
if you follow a common career path,
even in one of these high-profile careers
I talk so often about on this channel.
And this is exactly the first key insight,
the first implication I
want to share with you
in this video, and this
is something that took me
quite a lot of time to figure
this out, but this means
that if you want to truly
achieve financial independence,
it is very, very, very
difficult to do this
based on a regular employment,
based on a regular job.
Again, even if you do work
for such a high-paced career,
of course, there are some
positions where this is possible.
Of course, there are
some people who achieve
maybe in considering a
partner, a senior partner rank,
and are able to keep such a role
throughout their professional life.
Of course, these people
will be able to achieve
these types of financial
guards, but of course,
these are only a very
small minority of people,
and I think you would not be wise
to follow strategy that
this would be exactly
the type of position that
you will find yourself in
at some point.
So what is the learning from that?
Well, if at some point you
do want to improve your life
to the better, you do want
to achieve financial freedom,
following this definition,
which, of course,
might not be the goal
of everyone, of course,
maybe you might have another vision,
that is completely fine for you as well.
You need to do to some extent
something out of the ordinary.
You need to look into entrepreneurship,
into developing your side projects,
doing something next to your regular job,
otherwise, just mathematically,
it's almost impossible
to achieve this.
The next principle I got a lot
out of for my personal life
is about avoiding the tyranny of the or,
and this is from a book I
picked up as a teenager.
It's from Jim Collins'
bestseller "Built to Last,"
a book I can very much recommend.
There's a link to it in
the video description.
Feel free to pick it up yourself.
And one of the things that
Jim Collins describes here
is that successful people are
able to avoid exactly that,
the tyranny of the or.
The tyranny of the or
describes a belief system
that many people think that
things can either be A or B,
but not the same time.
It can either be like this or like that,
but having both things at the same time,
doing both things at the same time,
both things being true at the
same time is not possible.
This is a contradiction that
many people have in their head,
and there are lots of examples for that.
I can either be a good person
or I can climb up the corporate ladder.
I can either spend time with my family
or I can use the evenings
to go out for sports.
I can either have fun
during my time in university
or I can be a good student
and write A's all the time.
Either or, or, or, or, or, or.
This exactly is the tyranny of the ors,
this limiting belief that
you cannot have it all,
that you cannot make
through several things
at the same time.
And how Jim Collins describes it,
the successful people are
able to actually embrace
the genius of the and.
It is very often absolutely possible
to achieve many of these,
maybe on the surface,
contradictory goals at the same time.
I claim that all of the
things I just talked about,
probably it is possible to
achieve all of them together,
and this is exactly a very
important mindset to adopt.
To some extent, maybe you
could claim that also my life,
I adopted exactly this mindset
by starting the YouTube channel, right?
I get questions all the time.
How is it possible to
work a full-time career
and also do all these YouTube videos?
Well, I do think that it is possible.
It's about priorities,
it's about wanting it,
setting yourself your goals.
So ask this for yourself.
What is your YouTube channel?
Of course, not claiming that everyone
should start a YouTube channel,
but what does this mean for you?
Where can you embrace the
genius of the and to enrich
your life, both personally
and professionally?
The next principle I'd like
to call being in the right
versus winning in life.
And my grandmother once
asked me, Heinrich,
do you want to be in the right
or do you want to achieve your goats?
Some people are obsessed
with being in the right.
They're literally willing
to lose all their existence,
to lose their sympathy that
other people have for them,
to lose money just to
prove other people wrong.
This is such a common
theme of human behavior
that the German author Heinrich Von Kleist
wrote a whole novel about it.
Michael Kohlhass, this tragic
actor who lost his whole life,
his whole existence indeed, just to prove
that he was in the right.
It's a classic of German literature.
I very much recommend you
to pick this up as well.
Examples for this behavior, big and small,
can be witnessed almost every day.
People willing to lose their sympathy
just to prove someone wrong,
people suing each other
over trivial stuff,
people getting involved
in heated arguments about
things that don't matter at all,
people correcting each other over things
that just do not matter for sure.
And yes, while I do not want to claim
that this is always wrong,
sure, there's some situations
where such a behavior would be justified,
I would claim that very
often this type of behavior
is usually just motivated by
fragile ego and wounded pride.
Of course, there's the natural instinct
to do something against it.
Always take a step back, ask yourself
what you actually want to achieve
and whether this really
helps you to get there.
So I'd love to Now at your view on this.
Do you agree with these principles?
Anything you'd like to add, I trust
this will be very insightful
for other people watching this.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm, subscribe.
Big, big thanks to the
members of the channel.
My name is Heinrich.
I release regular videos
here on the channel.
See you again next week and bye-bye.